at jewish writer not a question but you
said with respect to kyle shanahan maybe
there is a strategy there that i am not
capable of grasping
it's called strategic transparency
players scouts others in the
organization and fans respect kyle's
honesty it also helps steer reporters
towards the stories rather than making
up some tabloid
negativity it actually has been very
successful for him i don't buy it
i don't buy it don't buy it
i don't buy it because
i look at the greatest coach of all time
in any sport bill belichick he doesn't
say crap
if if there was value to strategic
transparency
bill belichick would be engaged in it
i think the most recent thing that
happened
sean mcvay invites kyle shanahan to
appear on sean mcvay's podcast kyle
shanahan
knows that if he says no he comes off
as chicken like marty mcfly
timely reference he doesn't want to be
called a chicken
he doesn't want to be perceived as a
chicken come on kyle we're just going to
talk
football come on what are you afraid of
we're just going to talk
we're just going to talk so kyle
basically allows himself to be shamed
into doing it because he doesn't want to
look like he's afraid of having a
conversation
on the record with his top rival
and clearly sean mcvay is his top rival
they play each other twice a year
mcveigh's got the team right now that
would be regarded as the best on paper
in the nfc west
and then kyle starts talking and kyle
says things
and i think once kyle gets to talking he
can't keep himself from saying things
so
you know let me let me let me give you
the best example
now i'm not this way anymore but there
was a time that
if i had one of those big ass bags of m
ms the peanut ones you know like the
the big giant one pound bag
if that thing was in my house
i could not resist eating all
of the peanut m ms in one sitting now
if it wasn't there i'm not thinking
about peanut m
ms i'm not going to go to the store and
buy a giant bag
of peanut m ms i can walk right by
that aisle at the grocery store and i
love going to the grocery store i can
walk
right by it and not buy the big ass
yellow bag
of peanut m ms but if that thing's in my
house
it's not surviving and i don't know i
just kind of came up with that because i
think it explains
how kyle needs to protect himself from
himself for me
it meant not letting the big ass bag of
peanut m
m's into the house for kyle i think it
means
not putting himself in situations where
he is going
to say stuff that does not help him
it does not help him to talk about how
he wanted matthew stafford it does not
help him
to talk about these issues openly
because at the end of the day as i said
yesterday the perception that's been
created
the 49ers wanted any quarterback they
could find they wanted to throw a rock
and get a quarterback who would be
better than jimmy garoppolo at the end
of the day they gave up three first
round picks and a third round pick to
draft a rookie
who is stuck behind jimmy garoppolo on
the depth chart barring whatever happens
at training camp
makes me think because i i've i don't
want to waver from my position
from the moment they traded up i said
well see you later jimmy
goodbye jimmy it's been nice hope you
find your paradise
i i still think that they're gonna
hope that some other quarterback gets
injured
and not jimmy g because then they'd
still own 25 million
and they can trade him and if they get
to that
last week of the preseason you know
there's not going to be a fourth
preseason game this year there's a bye
week they have time to shape the rosters
that's when they go to jimmy g and they
say hey bro
we can't pay you 25 million trey lance
is ready to go
you want to stay you got to take 15
million
pay cut and you you're probably gonna be
on the bench
we'll keep you but you're not making 25
million and then or maybe they just cut
them maybe they don't even give them the
chance
to take less maybe they say we're all in
with trade lands because look if we
can't trust you to stay healthy as the
backup
how can we trust this day or this is the
starter how can we trust you to stay
healthy as the backup
so all this talk
from shanahan and all these admissions
that they wanted matthew stafford sam
darnold
aaron rodgers mac jones trey lance
i it makes it even more confusing that
they would be ready to go into the 2021
season with jimmy garoppolo
as the starter because if he does stay
healthy all year like he did two years
ago i mean it's not like he's gerald
ford
tripping down the steps of the airplane
every time he gets off of it
2019 he went wire to wire 2018 he didn't
2020 he didn't 20 21 maybe he goes wire
to wire
maybe you get back to the super bowl
maybe he misses a throw with the game on
the line
but we went to the super bowl we're
gonna dump the guy that took us to the
super bowl
i just look i
i i still think the 49ers have been
freaked out by the fact that they were
caught looking on patrick mahomes and
they swung and missed on tom brady
i i believe that uh
i i i just i don't see the benefit
and to the extent that there is
strategic transparency going on
i don't think it's a good plan because
it's created the impression
that the 49ers who are led by a coach
that i think could become the next bill
belichick and i still believe that
he just needs to put a sock in it and
that runs counter to every instinct that
i have
when it comes to operating
a media outlet that is premised on
people talking and i'm frustrated by the
fact that bill belichick won't talk
because there are things you can say
that don't hurt you strategically
i just i think that if if shanahan wants
to be bill belichick
he needs a good consigliere he needs
somebody who can whisper in his ear kyle
stop it just stop it just don't do it
don't do it
when you think about doing it do the
opposite
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports